شكل تطور سلاح المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
السنوات الماضيه هاجسه اسرائيل ومحرك
حروبها على قطاع غزه سعيا لتجريد المقاومه
من قدراتها بين ان جولات القتال بما فيها
تلك الدائره الان اثبتت نجاح الفصائل في
الحفاظ على ترسانتها وقدرتها على الرد
وفرض معادله ردع جديده مع الاحتلال اساسها
الالم المتبادل رغم اختلال ميزان القوه
فها هي صواريخ المقاومه تنهال بالمئات على
مناطق الاحتلال ومستوطناته من سديروت وحتى
تل ابيب مرورا بعسقلان
هذه العمليه المستمره والمتصاعده سمتها
المقاومه ثار الاحرار وهي تجربه تنسيق
وثيق بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه من خلال
الغرفه المشتركه في غزه
قبل اقل من عام كان العمق الاسرائيلي ايضا
تحت وطاه رشقات صاروخيه اذ استهدفت
المقاومه تل ابيب ومطار بالغريون واسود
وبئر السبع وعسقلان
كانت تلك عمليه وحده الساحات في شهر اغسطس
من العام الماضي حيث اطلقت سرايا القدس
الذراع العسكريه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
مئات الصواريخ ردت على اغتيال جيش
الاحتلال عددا من قادتها
على ان المواجهه الاوسع والاكثر شراسه
كانت تلك التي اخذت فيها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ولا سيما حركه حماس زمام
المبادره قبل عامين بالضبط
ووجهت ضربات صاروخيه مكثفه وفي وقت متزامن
على اسرائيل ردا على جرائمها بحق القدس
والمقدسيين كانت تلك عمليه سيف القدس في
ايار مايو من عام 2021 التي اطلقت خلالها
المقاومه اكثر من 4000 صاروخ وصل بعضها
الى مطار رامون على بعد اكثر من
220 كيلومترا من غزه
وقد استمرت عمليه سيف القدس احد عشر يوما
وخلف الثلاثه عشره قتيلا اسرائيليا واكثر
من ثلاثمائه كما رسخت وحده العمل
الفلسطيني المقاوم
في نوفمبر عام 2019 وردا على اغتيال بعض
قادتها شنت سرايا القدس الذراع العسكريه
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي قصفا صاروخيا على
اسرائيل في عمليه اطلقت عليها اسم صيحه
الفجر قبل ذلك بخمس سنوات ردت المقاومه
الفلسطينيه على اغتيال قاده من حركه حماس
بهجمات صاروخيه على العمق الاسرائيلي في
عمليه سميت العصف الماكول اطلقت كتائب
القسام خلالها اكثر من ثمانيه الاف صاروخ
على مدى 51 يوما
وقد لقي اكثر من 70 اسرائيليا مصرعهم فضلا
عن تمكن المقاومه من ارسال مسيرات الى
العمق الاسرائيلي وتعطيل الملاحه الجويه
في مطار تل ابيب
اما عمليه حجاره السجيل في نوفمبر من عام
2012 فكانت ردا من المقاومه الفلسطينيه
بنحو 1500 صاروخ على اسرائيل لاغتيالها
احمد الجعبري قائد كتائب عز الدين القسام
الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس وقد استغرقت
جوله القتال تلك ثمانيه ايام وخلفت 20
قتيلا اسرائيليا ومئات الجرحى وخسائر
ماديه هائله